So I was reading your book
and there's just something that I wanted to point out
because I just, it really, really spoke to me.
It's the dedication.
And it says here,
if you are reading this book, it's dedicated to you.
I love that so much.
(audience applauding)
Thank you.
Well, it's a book, it's really a book about,
you know, I write humor books,
but I got COVID early on and I was really sick,
and it's really how
I coped during COVID with my family.
And I felt that whoever read this book,
as we all went through
this global pandemic,
Yup.
There is sort of something for everybody in there.
So it's something I felt that we all went through together.
So that's why I dedicated it like that.
And it's also a global pandemic,
so I'm hoping this will be translated
into Turkish, and Arabic, and all the languages.
As it should be.
As it should be. Yeah.
Everybody needs to laugh and you're so funny,
you keep us laughing.
But let's go into a vision, fly on the wall moment of you
and your husband, George, mid COVID.
I heard you guys were watching Love Island.
Yeah, let me, I'm married to not George Clooney,
as everybody thinks.
(audience laughs)
George Stephanopoulos,
who is a a very smart, brilliant Rhodes scholar.
Yeah, like,
(audience applauding)
They're clapping for him.
award-winning journalist,
Yes, yes.
political advisor like,
Yes.
in the eye of the tornado of politics for decades.
But something happened in COVID
I think to all of us,
where you kind of went down to your base level,
and my two daughters kept running in and saying,
guys you've got to watch Love Island Australia.
And we were like, what? What are you talking about?
And one of them was like,
it's just about people that hook up,
and then they get voted off an island.
I was like, well, I'm in.
(audience laughs)
And very shortly,
George Stephanopoulos was hooked to Love Island Australia.
To the point where he was going,
I mean, it was almost like,
if you've ever seen him on election night,
he's calling things like a journalist.
So he would say like, wait a second,
so they had sexual intercourse
but she's actually smitten with him.
And we were like, oh, I guess if you wanna put it that way.
(audience laughs)
And we got so hooked on it
that one night we had a Love Island Australia dinner party,
the four of us, and we had to wear
bathing suits and makeup.
No.
Yeah.
So there's one photo, which no one can ever see,
or George will leave me,
but, and nor do you wanna see me in a bikini during COVID,
No, I do.
but I had
bikini, heels, full-on makeup,
we could only speak with an Australian accent.
Oh, my God. That's so fun.
It was so fun and yet, so crazy.
So you got into theme, talked to me about Mad Men,
did you like binge the whole show?
Yes, I did, for the second time in my life.
So you're watching
Don Draper.
Yes. So I'm watching
Don Draper, who is an alcoholic slander in the show.
Yes.
And so,
And you love him
all the more for it.
Of course.
So sick,
you loved him.
You want him even more.
Yeah.
And I was sick as a dog.
I had COVID very early on in March.
I had a really high fever.
And this was when you quarantined for three weeks.
And so my whole family was downstairs.
I was up in this room, like the movie, the room
for three weeks straight.
And I got so loopy that I thought
that I was married to Don Draper,
and George, my husband came in one day
with the mask and the gloves and, you know
gave me my soup and bread
Grow fat.
like I was in prison,
and I yelled at him and I was like
if you think, sleeping with one of your secretary.
And he was like, oh my God, you're crazy.
You were crazy when I married you, you're crazier now.
George was just like, he called our doctor,
and he was like, she's delusional,
is that part of the thing?
And even seeing the picture of him now-
It's like, hurtens you right back.
It does. I go that's my ex-husband Drew,
I don't wanna talk about this right now.
Right, exactly.
(audience laughing)